il pour une nouvelle car au cannet le
répertoire est échangé il a plus joué
avec détroit joe pile a commencé à jouer
avec des quatre et ils jouent une
variante d' avance donc ça enchaîne les
noirs qui récupère le pion les blancs
qui récupère aussi c'est kathia rock
alors france et 5 et princesses inquiets
des 6 check et bien installant des six
qui est solide fou g4 s'en prend aux
cavaliers tour c'est un s'en prend aux
cavaliers alors est ce que est ce qu'il
faut faire qui est 17 pour attaquer aux
cinq pattes il faire comment comment tu
arrives à décider le problème de ce
cavalier qui a aidé cette part est quand
même assez logique mais bon on ne
calcule rien la haye et prendrait cette
épreuve et cette attention les amis
il ya un gros problème gros problèmes
sur le pion bessette donc dame b6 d'un
v6 forcé que va-t-il jouer comment
va-t-il répondre à cette à cette attaque
et c'est cathy répond sur le cavalier
dames c'est cette il y va est-ce qu'on
retourne en d6 avec la dame avec le
cavalier qui vend des six lada niva
d'amd si ça allait l'attention lescure
ivoire dame prend des six échange le
pion va reprendre le cavalier c'est très
chaud les amis peut-être qu'il veut
reprendre du cavalier b6 et il n'a pas
de coût pour pour pour menacer ce
cavalier à l'épée quatre cavaliers prend
b4 c'est plus ou moins forcés pour ces
quatre la double attaque mais y'a
peut-être faut pas trop y aura la tour
emprise de l'autre côté c'est incroyable
les gens qui à vallée des saints qui
couvrent olala ça envoie de partout ils
n'avaient rien vu mais ça y va c'est du
coup par coup ça joue bien fou prend des
cinq qui peut arriver à tout moment
il faut calculer tous à la tour qui va
reprendre le cam a lyon des six qui sera
cloué mêlée f6 apsys mais est-ce grave
est ce qu'on peut jouer avec f4 on
consolide le cavalier l'option passé
cavaliers aussi sur le cavalier
bloqueurs qui défend le pion tour d un
tour f4 échange les tours tours s'est
incarné tour sur l'échiquier tour des
quatre il veut quand même échangé il
impose les changes ou pas il impose rien
du tout mais il le fait lui même
cavalier ses 5 3 2 3 j'ai l'impression
que les blancs sont craints entre quand
même en train de prendre le lead dans
cette partie le pion aux 5 est très fort
et on voit le roi qui est en train de
monter sur l'échiquier tour f1 il
attaque mais roi des cas trois des cinq
ça va partir
la tour qui va probablement venir
défendre derrière le pion attention les
amis l'euro en dessin que le roi qui
revient 17 sur wade s'est tu sais quoi
blême est ce qu'il ya un problème n'y a
peut-être pas de problème qu'elle prend
à sept y prend le pion tout de même mais
les noirs qui peuvent rien menacé la
tour en d2 qui est impérial tour f4 avec
aucune idée à part en cavalier c6 couvre
tout il veut jouer pour eux aussi s'ils
vont envoyer le pion cavaliers aussi ce
qui bloque un échec deux échecs qui
gagnent un peu de temps peut-être trois
échecs pour faire le jeu des trois
échecs non cavaliers des quatre la
finale de purée forcément gagnante les
amis puisqu'il est un pion de plus mais
un échec tout re 4 il vient devant le
pion sur tours deux sûrement il veut
échanger roi e6 leroy qui recule et on
menace une découverte découverte qui a
lieu en f 5 mai qu'un valide et 5
contres échec c'est quoi ce bordel sur
roy sait si c'est tourcoing dessin qui a
valu aux 7 donc il fait encore un échec
croît aussi ce qui est étranger cet
échec imparable prise prison de cinq
tours 2 c'est fini cavale et h5 tahri
qui s'est fait juste dominés dans la
phase tactique qui abandonne il ya trois
points d'écart
allez c'est reparti cavaliers f3 donc
tahri qui à moins 3 il doit vraiment
recoller au sens donc on retombe dans
une slave cela vous il peut sortir le
fou puisque avait pas de cavalier en c3
le foot est sorti angers 4,6 à
l'hercules de fond h5 on va mettre le
feu au nom des six et ça va partir à
léon warocqué ça va jouer avec le feu en
question en b2 dont qui empêche un peu
de jouer au sein qu'on prend le contrôle
de la case de 5 on échange les fous à 4
à 4 pour revenir un peu déstabilisé ce
fou éventuellement en b2 un petit coup
d'un v6 pour être jouables un jour mais
pour le moment il ya ces cinq le pion f4
qui est bien placé il consolide la case
de 5 peut être un jour g4 g5 pour
attaquer droit qui a aidé 3 couvre fois
à troyes en échange le fournisseur
mauvaise où il était gênant prise prise
est ce que pk tu peux jouer pour
l'enfermement de dames avoir avoir parce
que cette dame n'a plus trop de cases
est-ce que cavalier b1 est une menace
ici cavale et bien qu' on fermerait la
dame noire tahri qui va devoir
rapidement trouver une solution plutôt
23 devra être présent pour être une
solution cavaliers e24 avec l'idée sur
cavaliers bien d'avoir cavaliers c3
est-ce qu'on peut simplement commencer
ici par tour c'est un tour c'est un
cavalier tr3 pas jouer quand même ça
semble pour le moment sauvé la baraque
mais attention il faut calculer
cavaliers c3 qui est forcé il ya aussi
l'idée de faire tourner cavaliers france
et 3 suites tour c'est un ici il joue
dame c2 qui est bien
or c'est tout reprend b1 la dame qui est
quand même bien enfermés mais pour le
moment elle survit et malheureusement
tahri qui a peut-être laissé passer sa
chance
le cavalier b6 qui revit qui va aller
vers des cinq qui s'en prend à eux trois
la dame qui va pouvoir sortir verser 3
tahri qui s'est trompé quelque part il
semblait que la dame pouvait être
enfermé on va juge jeter un oeil avec
l'ordi sur cavaliers 4 et à ce gagnant
ou pas je vais vous le dire tout de
suite et non il n'y avait rien pour
enfermer la dame
la dame de vente forest qui était en
sécurité
en semi sécurité tout de même mais
comment faire comment faire maintenant
pour les noirs parce qu'il ya quand même
l'idée de faire quatre tours c3 est il
fait cavalier f6 acquis des cavaliers 4
que se passe-t-il maintenant sur
cavaliers f2 cavalière de cas et des
simples retour protègent cavaliers de d1
alors l'idée de chaldéen ses cavaliers
c3 qui les prend des 5es tour ces trois
jeux pihouet qui réussit pas à s'en
sortir car valiev de a peut-être quatre
étaient imprécis qui sait pas sur
plusieurs options ici cavalia de demain
on va jouer ces 5 adam g iii à la dame
qui ressort de l'autre côté complètement
inattendu la dame qui ressort de l'autre
côté et e5 maintenant qu'ils jouent sur
le double clouage quel magicien il est
plus forts en bulles est il s'est repris
il a dû manger quelque chose
il s'est bien repris et là maintenant la
dame qui est plus enfermer peut-être un
petit coup de g5 un g6 f5 a maintenant
il joue sur la fourchette
c'est chaud les amis à les cavaliers
chez 4 il faut la gagner quel qui peut
revenir on allait se comprend f6 oui y'a
pas de dames j'ai cinq échecs mais
quelqu'un cac attaqués va se faire
contre attaqué de partout peut-être ta
meuf de ici est ce que ça tient est-ce
que tout tient oui tout tient pour le
moment peut-être dame g5 du coup pour
les noirs pour menacer h5 s'est
immédiatement joué prise prise
un petit coup de damages te pour faire
des échecs nauroy h de plus sécurisant
e-menaces quel point qui avait dû
prendre 5 qui va être joué non le pion
qui avance la turquie peut venir en
géant elle vient à eux deux
dames f3 attention il protège le pion à
deux le roi qui montrent la dame qui
vient les changes de dames qui va être
bientôt effectif mais il faut encore se
méfier parce que le roi s'activent le
roi fait mieux que s'activer il parle de
partout peut-être tomber un tour d2 ici
j'ai l'impression que les blancs se sont
compliqué la vie au le piège
oh là là au nom il ya cavalli ckt
cavaliers d2 on sait pas fini cette
partie à roy prend aux cavaliers sefa
folie
mais qu'est ce qu'il a fait à rihanna
indiqué ce qu'il a fait il s'est
compliqué la vie de manière assez
inexpliqué et inexplicable il aurait
vraiment pu faire plus simple
il a tellement voulu assurer qui s'est
auto arnaquer or il a encors la finale
de cavaliers je trouve qui la gèrent
assez mal le cavalier noir qui va
pouvoir revenir s'échanger contre le
pion aux il a très mal géré cette
position avec une pièce de plus il a
voulu trop trop trop assuré et b un
cavalier donc si vous voulez faire un
cavalier vous pouvez utiliser la touche
alt même si vous avez la dame
automatique la touche alt vous permet de
faire un cavalier et d'ailleurs c'était
pas obliger un peut-être trois profs 4
et est même plus fort peut-être qu'il
fallait avec les noirs garder le pion en
vie et manger les pions mais c'est assez
assez assez incroyable cette partie
ariane paris qui vraiment veut trop
assuré le coup faut simplement la gagne
et les amis simplement la gagner il veut
éviter tous les risques et éviter de se
faire arnaquer et c'est pour ça qu'ils
se faire arnaquer rappelez vous de ce
conseil c'est un conseil et co plus que
je viens de vous donner
mais quand vous avez peur de vous faire
arnaquer c'est encore pire en fait
larnaca d'arriver encore encore plus
vite
faites attention alors là un petit coup
comme si ce pourrait être jouable
éventuellement et s'est fait une attaque
de nuit une attaque de nuit il est 22
heures il fait la tacc de nuit et il va
il va jouer sur les cases noires il y
avait une belle partie de fischer là
dessus mais attention parce que si les
noirs réussissent à jouer simple attaque
de nuit est complètement débile
puisque les noirs réussi juste à pousser
leurs centres comme des brutasses et les
blancs viennent de faire un gros cadeau
alors là il faut vraiment en profiter
le match n'est pas fini il reste encore
20 minutes de jeu on sent que
que j'ordonne pourrait craquer on sent
qu'il est quand même sur le rupteur
attention tout de même les noirs qui
n'ont pas invoqué finalement et qui sont
interdits de rock par la tour f 1 qui
est très bien placé donc attention tout
de même la sueur fou et dont on en
profitera pour faire le petit rock donc
le fou va sûrement repartir dame f3
d'ahmed 3 c'est bien joué
est-ce que fou et s'inquiète une option
ici pour les noirs fuglsang jouer g4 et
ça y est c'est reparti c'est reparti
c'est reparti dans le n'importe quoi
enfin le n'importe quoi dans la mêlée
tactique alors est ce qu'on peut faire
pions prendre puis on prend qui on prend
sur dame prend il doit vouloir faire
soit eux deux soit d'alger cinq
cavaliers g3 a bien joué et couvre la
case h5 et il attaque la dame
il gagne la qualité est là il peut pas
faire grand roque
mais tours j'ai huit tours j'ai vite il
assure il se met sur la colonne mais là
il ya un problème là pour les noirs en
bullet c'est très difficile à jouer
objectivement il doit être pas mal aux
quatre avec ide de est fou des quatre
échecs pour ceux des clous et eux
devaient être joués maintenant qu'elle
est l'idée sur 2 2 qui menace ou des
quatre et il a pas vieux deux cavaliers
f6 cavaliers f6 où il avait tout vu mais
cavalière 6 3 et 7 peut être roi des 8 1
rouaf cette série damages 5
trois des huit que ce pas si sûr
cavaliers pros g8
peut-être il veut simplement faire un
échec et à les prendre a appris en a eu
un
en tout cas la dame qui donne des échecs
mais le roi j'ai l'impression qu'il est
très heureux d'être parti en 17 sur qui
les projets vite il fera simplement qu'
on prend un f1 échec intermédiaire
palmarès des coûts des chèques de jopie
j'ai permis au roi de passer de 8 à 17
de se promouvoir dont il prend en propre
au g8 ces tours de plus cette fois ci
est ce qui va craquer avec une tour de
plus ça m'étonnerait ya plus d cheikh
touré fut this place bien il a le temps
alors là faut pas paniquer
encore une fois il est en train il se
fait embrouillé on sent qu'il n'a pas
trop l'expérience du bullet
malheureusement et qui se fait
magouilles et il a peur d'alger s'est
tallé tour j'ai six mois s'est laissé
gagner qui a valu à 6,3 b6 tout reprend
g4 bon il faut quand même peut-être pas
abuser ya dame de plus
ça devrait suffire mais bon ils jouent
la montre parce que parce qu'il est
devant au score c'est pas forcément
voilà on a on a vu on a vu plus sport
l'école c'est l'école gris tchouk c'est
l'école hikaru et il se fait maths est
allé il ya deux points d'écart on voit
vraiment que tu arrivais pas il est pas
loin
il est vraiment pas loin dans ce match
j'aimerais bien voir une feinte de une
fin de match au couteau avec avec un
seul point d'écart ce serait vraiment
beau ce serait intéressant ça peut le
faire
donc on a vu une espagnole mode chiant
kétou et les blancs qui ont pris le
centre les blancs qui ont installé les
pions des 4 4 mais peut-être sur roc
l'idée c'était de faire cavaliers pros
ou 4k et prend 1,4 et des cinq là elle
femme au zoo fourchette les blancs qui
ont envoyé aux cinq cavaliers g4
peut-être le petit rock ou h trois
intermédiaires aussi intéressant pour
chasser ce cavalier fou g5 aussi est un
coup le coiffe si c'est tabou le roi
serait dans le clouage donc dames 8
semble fort c'est peut-être cavaliers
des cinq maintenant cavalier des 5 qui
serait courageux parce que ça laisse
cavaler prendre cinq voiliers en bullet
c'est un peu dangereux
il préfère rockets ils gardent cahier
des cinq classes jouables encore un
peut-être mais attention de cavaliers
pourrait ne pas ressortir pour le moins
gardes le fouillent maintenant h3 est
une menace le cavalier g4 n'a plus de
gaz puisque la case agissez maintenant
obstrué par le pion cavaliers à 5 menace
le fou le four vian à eux deux il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont en train de
traîner le cavalier qui est mal placée
en a cinq
il ya beaucoup de problèmes pour les
noirs la hache 3 semble à gagne pas une
pièce sur et f4 et fois je cavaliers
prend h 2 comment continuer et puis on
prend ici c'est une option cavaliers des
cinq finalement qu'ils aient joué avec
l'idée d'aller chercher finalement sept
tours dont 4,4 il va chercher le fou ici
les
et blanc allaient blanc qui doit faire
attention damages 5 qui vient comme une
surprise mais il ya peut-être un coup
comme kaka étrangers cinq si on prend g3
fou pranger quatre dames prend h2 alors
peut-être vous il faut jouer fh 3 et sur
puis on prend qui on prend et on n'a pas
le temps de mater en h2 puisque le
cavalier seul est en vie donc il ya des
échanges de partout les blancs qui sont
mal autant mais matériellement ça a
l'air sympa le fou qui va essayer de
venir en bessette j'imagine des cinq
voies l'accueil c'est 7 qui est venu
pour sécuriser le pion des cinq
histoires de fermer la diagonale du fou
matériellement où en sommes-nous il
c'est une tour de plus nette pour les
blancs une nouvelle fois qu'ils
échangent les pièces petit à petit et
qui vont probablement l'emporter à moins
que à moins d'un exploit un coup comme
dam des quatre ici paraît sympa dame e2
encore mieux peut-être d'un jeu de dames
f2 les noirs qui essayent d'embrouillés
et qui arrive une nouvelle fois
incroyable il peut faire d'un probable
futur premier fuite améliora roi
j'essaie tours fc tours fc tours f1
ouais là il ya réseau de maitreya tour
avec sept matches qui arrivent au
prochain il va peut-être falloir jouer
h5 donc ils bougent la dame une fois il
va faire h5 maintenant un échec et deux
échecs et où il a demandé quatre est mal
placée et ça fait et ça fait plus 1
seulement attention attention jarden
j'ordonne qui s'est pas nourris entre
les parties s'est pas hissé pas nourri
il sait pas nourris on va regarder un
petit peu au niveau des cernes
je vais jeter un oeil il fait une sale
tête
j'ordonne tête de quelqu'un d'un peu
fatigué il est un peu sombre il hébreu
sont j'ai envie de dire marianne tahri
lui pas du tout marquée qui a le visage
le visage encore frais et pourtant il
est mieux classé en bulles est un genre
jeunes je leur donne qui est classée en
bullet aux alentours de 2007 140 alors
qu'ariane moins expérimentés ils gagnent
des points maintenant il est monté à
24,72 mais au début du match il n'était
qu'à deux mille trois cents et quelques
dons qu'on a on a à faire à
un spécialiste un semis spécialiste de
de la cadence face à un joueur moins
expérimentés mais on sait qu'en bull est
le surtout que c'est dur c'est du bullet
avec +1 donc c'est un peu moins punitif
si vous n'êtes pas entraîné et on sait
on sait on sait l'importance d'être
encore fred être encore lucide et vend
de forêts ce qui manque un peu de
lucidité justement dame b 6
est ce que le pion b2 et emprises
peut-être peut-être pas mais ils jouent
tranquillement pour amener le cavalier
verser 4 les noirs que les blancs qui
tente de jouer la taxe sur le roi est ce
qu'un petit coup comme tour des huit va
être jouée par par les noirs n'ont même
pas parce qu'attention là l'idée de
l'idée des blancs c'est une idée tribu
les tests c'est juste d'attaquer comme
un bourrin malgré les changes des dames
mais ça peut ça peut être efficace ça
peut passer
attention j'ai l'impression de là il a
pris une très bonne décision le joueur
néerlandais
alors on imagine un coup comme tours
j'ai un tour des 3 rise il veut il veut
il veut partir pour tous rage trois
tours age 2 attention il y aura du
cavalier pranger 5
attention ne pas être trop gourmand non
plus avec les blancs parce que les noirs
hamas dont il veut faire tour g3 il
prépare sa part est quand même très
dangereux cavaliers des quatre fous ces
quatre là c'est en train de construire
des 5 et b3 il réussi à enfermer le fou
mais maintenant il va falloir résister à
l'autre menace il peut peut-être joué f6
surtout rage 3i s'échapper l'aï réussi à
s'échapper
il y avait peut-être quelque chose à un
moment pour les blancs ni s'échappe tour
d2 ah oui il souvent hills où il va
repasser colonnes d aller faut jouer un
peu plus vite
côté tarifs au garder le temps le quai
qui repart en d4 il a peur de rien le
fou qui revit sur la diagonale mais
l'idée c'est roy e set et enfermement de
tours qu'est-ce qu'il est malin
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qu'il est
fort impressionnant tard il a
impressionnant le piège
tim roi et fit cavalier dégâts et
abandon abandon incroyable égalisation
de taris vous m'auriez dit ça il ya une
heure je n'y aurais pas cru
oh la la il est là là là la chute
physique de jarden à forest faut
vraiment qu'ils qu'ils se fassent un
entraînement course à pied qui
travaillent le travail le cardio là ça
ne va pas du tout incroyable incroyable
alors que tahri semblait vraiment en
difficulté pendant tout le match
il semblait dans le dur les occasions
ratées les occasions ratées dans le cinq
plus un le début du iii plus sain où il
domine oui oui où il convertit pas on le
sent moins fort on le sent moins rapide
et là tout d'un coup ça se joue vraiment
dans la tête ça se joue vraiment dans
dans les jambes j'ai envie de dire ce
match au final c'est vraiment la chance
là pour pour notre ami néerlandais mais
notre ami néerlandais qui est quand même
toujours lie à 11 partout il peut se
refaire la cerise
il peut se refaire la cerise mais atari
qui joue maintenant avec des convictions
regardez-moi ça le fond en b2 qui
contient qui maintient que cinq pour
qu'on enlève 6 le cas où le fou en d3 le
pion h qui pousse
il a des convictions maintenant le
joueur le joueur norvégien
il est plein de conviction alors que son
adversaire est plein de doutes il peut
d'ailleurs joué peut-être fou projet six
prises g6 et d'un projet si ça peut être
une idée hein parce que lorsque les
blancs les noirs prendront ici on
pourrait imaginer quelque chose un peu
comme ça même si peut-être que sam ath
pas il ya du contre eux je mets ça peut
ça peut être une idée on va voir comment
il continue il a justement continuer par
cette prise et c'est la partie alors
cavaliers g5
il va y avoir foule prend g5 sa part et
fort ses pions prend mai
que se passe-t-il ici damev 7 sur un
aveu de faiblesse et adam h7 maths j'ai
envie de te dire fou 17 ans risque d'un
match 5 kg si c'est une idée pour aller
mater le roi noir en force d'un procès
deux et j'ai six noms cavaliers des deux
joué il veut éviter dames quatre échecs
n'y a pas d'échec tout reprend f2 menace
dame prend des deux rois prend il aurait
peut-être pu faire damage cet échec
intermédiaire mais il ne l'a pas fait
alors que se passe-t-il
il ya peut-être un échec perpétuel et
encore le roi repart en h3 fou ici
damache huit échecs la tour eiffe un tas
me ranger cette tour h7 ça me paraît
très mauvais ce qu'il a joués en
laissant la tour arrive en f1 il a
laissé les olives les les blancs
compléter le rock le rock est réalisé et
dale ses sept matches en un incroyable
il voit plus rien il ne voit plus rien
j'ordonne band forrest qui n'a plus
d'essence dans le ja plus d'essence
c'est fini c'est fini
celaa c'est la panne c'est l'ascension
de l'alpe d'huez avec avec le mot
m'échappe mais mais vous allez me le
dire dans le chat quand tu peux plus
avancer à vélo âgées plus le mot vous
allez me le dire j'ai plus le mot mais
laïque cal ical complètement incroyable
il voit plus rien ouais la fringale
voilà la fringale
il ya une fringale une fringale et cette
variante là je la connais bien c'est une
vente que gekko n'est recommandée à un
de mes élèves justement d'erquy et
néerlandais et là je peux vous dire
qu'il va y avoir du fou prend 2,6 et que
ça va faire très mal
mon avis taris il n'a pas la bonne
position au là il va y avoir du foot pro
réussissent là à mon avis il va y avoir
du fou prend aussi ce qui va rôder c'est
pas la bonne variante ça vous prend ici
je sais pas si ça marche et je vais
mettre un petit peu d'ordi parce qu'il
ya quand même cavaliers pros m6 avec
fourchette mais demeure un problème est
d'alger cas très fort aussi leur dit
qu'ils donnent plus + 5 ici est fou
prend aussi ce maintenant s et lâchant
que la totale
ariane paris qui
et après le lead qui s'est relâché et ça
se paye cash
ça se paye cash il reste moins de dix
minutes les fringales on sait qu'on peut
se remettre un une fringale
on peut se remettre il suffit de il
suffit de s'alimenter mais le problème
c'est quand vous alimentez il faut une
vingtaine de minutes
il faut 15 20 minutes pour que ça
revienne c'est pour ça que je vous
disais tout à l'heure qu'à 15 minutes
qu'à 15 minutes 20 minutes avant la fin
des trois mais je dis faut absolument
qu'ils aillent vite s'alimenter sinon ça
arrivera jamais au cerveau et c'est
l'erreur qu'il a faite il a dû aller
s'alimenter entre les parties et
malheureusement et malheureusement il
lui faut du temps mais peut-être qu'il
peut être remis la grèce ça fait 20
minutes qu'il a mangé ça peut commencer
à arriver au cerveau ça peut se remettre
donc
peut-être que van de forrest va se
remettre de cette fringale en tout cas
là il est complètement gagnant il va
aller gratter encore la tourache 8 avec
dame g7 et dame prend la fuite
voilà ils grattent higueras tout le
matériel il gratte ou ski à gratter mais
même là il et il me rassure pas quand
mes amis me rassure pas avant de forest
il a quand même y réfléchit quand même
très longtemps à la pollution semblait
beaucoup plus facile il est quand même
complètement gagnant mais on se sent
qu'il est il est plus en confiance mon
là ça va aller [ __ ] au f5
il va quand même gagné mais il n'est pas
rassurant kantari qui joue un petit peu
peut-être par inertie juste continuer la
partie
il va rester un peu plus de sept minutes
pour la conclusion à les égalités douze
ennemis douze ennemis match très serré
ariane paris va-t-il retourner dans la
dans la rue lopez wii continue à la rude
au psg si ce qui c'était assez mal passé
dans la partie précédente mais du coup
ils jouent avec des six coups des sept
îles a changé deux variantes avec les
noirs ça s'était très mal passé mais
cette fois ci ça va aller ça échange ça
va jouer bons fous qu'on pouvait fou
c'est tendu s'est tendue s'est posée
position 'vendre' forez qui les a très
bien joué en début de match bon il avait
là une position un peu un peu dans le
même esprit mais avec les blancs avec le
petit avantage mais les a très bien
tourné
va-t-on va-t-on que que va-t-on voir
dans cette danse est partie à l'effet
mais va mettre des taquets vaillance et
4 dames c4 ils jouent les changes des
dames il veut jouer la petite finale
c'est petit avantage qui a lancé quatre
on l'a beaucoup vu côté
côté ventes forest voilà il ya rien n'y
a rien obtenu
kaya 5e cinq sages ou la contre attaque
sur le centre
c'est peut-être vendre forêt ce qu'est
en train de prendre le dessus dans cette
partie le roi de vente forrest qui monte
il a le contrôle du centre avec les
pions f5 et e5 sajoo tour des deux tours
d un rapport il n'a pas forcément pris
le dessus je suis peut-être allé un peu
fort mais à mon avis il a à minima bien
égaliser
à toi un fief six cavaliers pro b cette
marche pas parce que quand cavalière
prend bessette qui protège la tour il
bougeait 3b si je suis pas convaincu que
ce soit un très bon coup ça donne quand
même la casse c'est si ce cavalier blanc
alors il s f5 pour le moment ma passion
partie avec laurent f1 histoire de ce
semi sécurisé ou pas si sûr foued de roi
et fins auxquelles on le joue dans cet
ordre là pourquoi pas
peut-être falloir attaquer sur la
colonne eu un jour mon tour h1 ça fait
pas très peur honnêtement cette tour a
beaucoup de mal à revenir en jeu parce
que ya le problème du pion à 7
ok abescat et des quatre cavaliers f5
maintenant mais qui est parée par quatre
bien jouer cavalier des quatre camps
mène donc ça échange le fou qui va
probablement venir en eux cinq positions
qui est très tendue à les prises prise
mais le roi plan maintenant qui est
mieux au c'est dur à évaluer le cavalier
en bullet qui est très dangereux les
amis ça peut se jouer à rien un coup
comme g4 peut marcher à un moment donné
d'ailleurs parce que surtout reprend il
à tour prend 1,4 mais ça faut encore le
voir mais il tourne le cavalier qui va
aller gratter à 4 le fou qui va être
super fort 5-fu e5 qui paraît fort aux
cavaliers b2o il craque iqra qui craque
allez il a craqué le fou aux cintres en
plus un vrai gros comme une maison
il allait aider le pion g et paré et b
bloquer le pion à c.difficile allez il
reste il reste plus que cinq minutes de
jeu mais moins quatre minutes un point
d'avancé pour tahri allez paris qui
retourne dans sa sacareau cannes mais
qui répètent pas la variante avec fois
f5 y joue la vente avec g6 donc ça c'est
une petite variante qui est pas super
bien réputé en partie longue mais si on
connaît pas et qu'on n'est pas capable
de débiter les coûts précis de théorie
avec les blancs ça se joue tout à fait à
le coup h quatre peut-être un peu
étonnant d'un côté parce que ça va aller
c'est fou j'ai quatre à voir ce qui va
se passer avec ce fou de cases blanches
qui peut venir angers 4 pour justement
mettre la pression sur le centre alors
ça joue comme une française maintenant
où on avait fermé le jeu et le roi noir
va peut-être filet sur du grand roque en
tout cas c'est une française dont on
sort le fou non pas du tout donc les
blancs qui vont attaquer à l'endroit ses
ouailles voilà c'est vraiment une
française avec les fermetures c4 fabien
vous dirai qu'il faut jamais faire ça
lorsque le roi ayant eu un après c'est
une variante avec les pions doublé
cependant c'est plus facile à jouer pour
les blancs mais a noté que le fou eu 2
peut pas rejoindre la bonne diagonale en
d3
et donc c'est un petit problème pour les
blancs si le pion était en b2 par
exemple le fourré pu revenir sur la
casse et donc les noirs qui ont joué
grand roque message ou quand même allé
droit ici même si le roi blanc est allé
droit parce que les pièces noires ont
beaucoup de mal à venir jouer des droits
parce que ceux qui ont eu cinq
verrouille vers où ils verront bien
l'échiquier ariane tahri qui s'activent
à mon avis ariane qui en train de
regarder s'il peut pas envoyer du matos
leroy qui va peut-être partir angers 3 1
jour en tout cas là les blancs ou angers
2 plutôt les blancs là sont très bien ne
vous faites pas d'illusions les blancs
même s'ils ont même si tout le jeu à
l'aller le droit comme je vous le disais
les pions centraux sont en train de
bloquer le centre est donc le roi n'est
pas du tout du tout du tout en danger la
tourache c'était très bien placé sur la
septième rangée ya beaucoup de choses à
manger il ya le pion au 6 qui est en
danger il ya du cavalier h5 peu rodé il
ya fou prend des 5 et 6 maintenant alors
attention escarmouches tactique en vue
d'un point f 4 pions dame prend d'un f3
et ça va rester je vous parlais de sa
tour en h7 qui a été très bien à placer
la colonne la septième rangée c'est la
rangée où il ya du trafic et ce trafic
là ils payent fouet f6 il va y avoir
pour projet set ça donne quoi
matériellement c'est une qualité plus le
pion passé mais attention il faut pas se
faire contrer côté blanc par du cavalier
b 4 pouces et 6 attention attention le
roi qui n'est pas très bien placé la
dame qui peut se réveiller vendre
forrest on vous l'a dit les dans le dur
il est dans le dur il peut y peu gaffe
et il est dans le dur et c'est pour ça
que tahri abondonne pas cavalier prend
ces trois marche pas parce qu'il ya le
pion il fait bessin qui sécurise cavale
ip66 protège
ouais c'est quand même bien joué de la
part de vente forrest vont te reste est
en train de bien bien bien mettre la
pression
ça défend encore fouet cette il veut
faire pousser 5 pour aller mater
éventuellement alors est ce que les
noirs vont réussir à créer une menace ou
c5 menace dame prend 1,7 et reprend à
cette matin b4 c'est pour sécuriser la
casse des cinq au cas où poussent et 6,6
revient et damas cinq mat bien joué bien
joué et bien joué de la part de jopie il
reste il reste de hausser la dernière
partie c'est la dernière partie donc
tout va se jouer sur une sicilienne
variante kahn ou pas donc c'est pas
vraiment ça on time à nos services
et hélas variant de cannes mais non ça
ne va pas jouer là dessus en cas de
match nul y aura un départage
attention donc faut trois qui étaient
captives à y avoir de nouveaux grands
rock ou pas ouais ça va ça à partir de
gros rock ça à partir avec 4 4,5
ça va attaquer à fond ils allaient blanc
riez atari donc il faut il faut il faut
il faut jouer leur va-tout là il faut
jouer leur va-tout il faut attaquer f 4
5 envoyé au centre il ya égalité faut
aller la chercher il a les blancs c'est
quand même une chance et c'est lui qui a
quand même
l'initiative pour le monde la partie h5
prend de l'espace à l'ale
roy et avec des idées parfois jusqu'à
était même parfois la tour qui naviguent
via la cinquième ranger c'est une idée
assez typique de cette sicilienne foot
est roi développement là si la dame
parents rêvent de lloret cavaliers g4 la
dame repart en f3 fouet celle ci peut
même jouer avec petit rock parfois on va
voir comment il décide mais grotte
paraît quand même plus logique et la
tour qui pourrait se développer via h5 y
jouer aux cinq changements de structure
de pions d'une structure qui maintenant
va plutôt ressemblé à une structure de
type kalachnikov avec le trou en d5 et
le petit fou g4 qui gagne la qualité
vont en forêt ce qualité du stade où ils
se penchent est née cavallier 4 tout
tombe
est-ce qu'il ya du cavalier des cinq
intermédiaire dans le foot on y peut pas
reprendre s'il n'ya pas fou g5
alors attention maintenant il a gagné la
qualité fou g5 qui menace il a fait
froid bien il a vu donc la qualité plus
mais le roi noir et pas forcément très
bien ça reste chaud la dame qui va
sûrement partir vers des six pour aller
gratouiller il peut aller gratter le
pion mais y'aura petit rock assez bien
joué notamment de 5 le fou qui va
revenir en f6 et les tours qui vont
venir vers la avère vers les droits le
fou qui vient f6 mais y'a pas de mal
parce que la dame en v6 couvre cavaliers
c'est cette menace cavaliers pros
investissent menaces qui avaient des
problèmes c'est ce qui va être joué la
tour qui va arriver au f5 la dame en f2
attention ma nourrice que la partie n'a
pas tourné d'un proche qu'à tours fc qui
arrive la dame qui vient tout colmater
d'am-dam d'eau qui va décaler pourtour
f5 ne se sera pas restaurée au 8 tours
vite qui a interdit tout rêve cinq dames
problème c'est que ça rend dans la
finale entre les grands la qualité
va-t-il rentrer dedans fous ces quatre
menaces ou prend des cinq impossible à
cause de dame prend il a raté des 5 fu
détroit le pion aux cas qui tombe le
plus rocade qui tombe là partir encore
tourner maintenant les noirs semblent
très bien les tours qui se double roi g7
le roi qui monte ce que la tour blanche
va réussir à monter un petit coup de
jets 3 pour ouvrir non roi de il évite
les tours un échec tour sain qui vient
au centre dam des trois dames des trois
dames des trois dames détroit que
va-t-il se passer autour d'eux et ce qui
va réussir à lecce 3 ouvrir les colonnes
devant le roi h3 ferme le jeu
maintenant il faut trouver absolument
une solution tout rêve qui à tour quatre
probablement pour venir couper la
quatrième rangée non il prend le pion
courageux est ce qu'il va faire tour 4
maintenant tour 4 pas réforme il ya
peut-être tour 5 pour proche d'eux était
quand même très risquée est très
courageux d'alger si ce retour g4 g5 ça
semble tenir vous prendrez 5 le pion
tombe maintenant il va y avoir un
décalage avec peut-être du tout
prends ces deux pour libérer le pion h
tout rejet de aussi jouable menace tout
reprend g3 attention les blancs sont
proches proche proche de la défaite tout
reprend g3 peut-être intermédiaire très
fort il semble rien y avoir pour les
blancs le fougueux quatre ans prises
d'un rêve de tout reprend eu quatre
points quatre dames 3 4 dames pranger 3
tient les noirs doivent trouver un ou
deux bons coups parce que le monde sur
le fil du rasoir
pour preuve si sûr dame prend ypres en
échec à plus des chaînes ya plus
d'échecs et celles à langon et c'est
gagné et c'est gagné vente forrest qui a
gagné c'est fini c'est fini
non il ya encore une partie non le temps
est fini on ne sait pas il ya écrit time
maintenant c'est fini il a gagné il a
gagné vendre forest au finish choi s'est
repris à il s'alimentait entre les deux
parties la gagne et oriane tahri qui
vient de découvrir sa défaite il a perdu
cette partie à il était pas loin dans la
partie précédente
on peut revenir dessus il avait une
bonne position
comment revenir sur la partie précédente
on va aller rechercher la partie
précédente et il était il était pas loin
je vais essayer de l'ouvrir dans le
temps dans le chat il était pas loin là
c'était ça s'est pas joué à grand chose
ça s'est pas joué à grand chose
je pense que je peux réussir à l'ouvrir
je vais je vais réussir à la mettre on
va on va jeter un oeil ensemble quand
même pour faire un débrief mais c'est
incroyable donc victoire de vente forest
j'ai envie de dire dans l'est dans les
arrêts de jeu il a réussi à gagner au
moment le plus important la dernière
partie s'est ressaisi et on a vu on a vu
les cernes qui sont partis mais bon la
position il était moins bien on va
revenir à mon avis faire cette position
là qui est un peu la position clé
finalement on va mettre un petit coup
d'ordi pour faire le débrief ouais il
était pas mal dame f2 qui est pas
vraiment une erreur d'alger cinq dames
e2 peut-être pas très bien placé cette
dame en vue de hisser mis sur la colonne
tour 8es du coup il a plus les tours f5
il a plus vraiment les tours f5 et c'est
là que ça s'est joué sous ses quatre des
cinq
il a mal géré ce moment et après c'était
fini il aurait fallu qu'ils réussissent
à faire du tour f5 peut-être même
directement
quitte à jouer tout de suite laissé d'un
proche d'eux
et veut et venir jouer un coup comme
d'amd 4 ou quelque chose comme ça à voir
le fouet fin et venir attaquer le point
f6 et la partie aurait pu aurait pu se
solder différemment donc voila voila
quoi ça se tient les amis un speech s à
rien ça se joue à rien en tout cas
c'était un très très très beau match
c'est un très beau match les amis une
saison de speech s qui débute de la plus
belle des manières et on se retrouvera
mardi prochain à 18h pour le match
oui face à non enfin de fil rouge à face
à face à marck snel alcantara et je vais
vous laisser avec une pub pour soutenir
twitch et chaque point comme qui nous
ont offert ce magnifique match donc
merci à eux merci à twitter merci à
jesse comme de nous avoir offert ce
magnifique spectacle et un match
vraiment vraiment palpitant